wir wollen jetzt noch etwas weiter über
die neuen strengeren maßnahmen sprechen
bei uns im studio noch immer unser
kollege alexander von schönburg aber ich
möchte auch noch jemanden mit dazu holen
in diese diskussion und zwar uns nun
zugeschaltet von der uni münchen
professor weiter mit denn wir sprechen
hier jetzt immer wieder über die korona
alleine wie wir es jetzt sozusagen etwas
vereinfacht umgangssprachlich nennen den
bewegungsradius von 15 kilometern von
der eigenen haustür wenn man sich in
einem landkreis befindet mit einer
instanz von über 200 die frage ist kann
man das wirklich gesetzlich regeln ist
es auf deutsch gesetz überhaupt möglich
dass man erwachsenen leuten sagt bis 15
kilometer und nicht weiter dürft ihr
euch von eurer haus zu entfernen
das ist an sich nichts neues das ist in
sachsen geltende rechtslage seit dem 14
dezember da hat sich soweit ich das
mitbekommen habe niemand so groß drüber
aufgeregt das heißt also das ist etwas
was eigentlich im werkzeugkasten der
deutschen akademie bekämpfung bis jetzt
schon vorgekommen ist ohne dass es
wahnsinnig große wellen geschlagen hat
andererseits muss man sagen so
wahnsinnig effektiv war es auch nicht
wenn man nach sachsen blickt
wenn man sich jetzt anschaut es gibt
diese regelungen heute informiert die
kanzlerin darüber dass es diesen
bewegungsradius gibt was hat das dann
für auswirkungen für die bürger und wird
sowas kontrolliert bestraft was ist los
wenn ich 16 17 kilometer überschreiten
also wie setzt man das ganze also
kontrollieren lässt sich das ganze nur
schwer wie sich auch bis jetzt schon
alle maßnahmen wahnsinnig schwer bloß
kontrollieren lassen
letztlich ist es ein appell an die
bürger nimmt es ernst bleibt zu hause
überschreite teuren ängsten
lebensbereich nur dann wenn es absolut
notwendig ist unabhängig davon muss man
aber sagen es gibt weiterhin zumindest
erwarte ich dass so viele triftige
gründe um diese 15 kilometer grenze zu
überschreiten
dass es da nicht wahnsinnig viele
strafen geben wird zumindest ist es aus
sachsen jetzt auch nicht überliefert
dass die dort jetzt schon geltende
regelung wahnsinnig viele beanstandungen
hervorgebracht hätte sie sagen es ja
ganz wichtig am ende ist das nicht mehr
als ein appell wahl kontrollieren kann
man es eh nicht das ist so wie bei den
anderen maßnahmen warum sagt man da als
regierung nicht ganz ehrlich leute wir
können jetzt eine maßnahme nach der
anderen verfassen warum bleibt ihr nicht
einfach zu hause
warum macht man dann solche dinge wie
eine 15 kilometer regel das macht
überhaupt keinen sinn wenn man weiß dass
man eben nicht kontrollieren kann ob man
15 17 20 25 kilometer entfernt das vom
wohnort ihr die nächste eskalationsstufe
wir eigentlich nur so eine regelung wie
sie in frankreich bestanden hat
einzuführen
nämlich dass ich tatsächlich im eigenen
viertel bleiben muss also nur um den
wohnblock gehen kann oder einen selbst
ausgestellten passierschein dabei haben
muss
davor schreckt die regierung zu recht
aus meiner sicht weiterhin zurück will
aber trotzdem ein zeichen der eskalation
sozusagen setzen will noch mal ein
deutliches zeichen setzen dass die
bisherigen maßnahmen nicht ausreichen
und dann kommt eben so was heraus wie
diese 15 kilometer grenze die aus meiner
sicht nicht wahnsinnig viel nützen wird
die aber auch nicht wahnsinnig viel
schaden wird also die diskussion die
heute zum beispiel in die sozialen
medien darüber geführt wurde
die halte ich angesichts der
auswirkungen auch für überzogen sind
spannender punkt sie sagen das wird
nicht viel schaden da möchte ich
alexander von schönburg fragen alexander
wenn wir aber
sehen was im sommer schon passiert ist
bei den demonstrationen wie sich leute
plötzlich radikalisiert haben weil es
bestimmte freiheitsrechte nicht mehr gab
was macht das mit diesen menschen dass
es jetzt eine 15 kilometer lange gibt
ich glaube es ist sehr gefährlich
regelungen zu erlassen und wenn man weiß
dass ich nicht eingehalten werden weil
das natürlich unterminiert sozusagen so
etwas wie ja die einsicht ich glaube
dass das dass das schwierig ist und ich
glaube dass wie ich vorhin schon gesagt
habe die akzeptanz dieser maßnahmen wird
vielen vielen sehr schwer fallen und
wird nur dann nicht sagen einmal kippen
in wirkliche revolten ist vielleicht zu
viel gesagt wird nicht so lange nicht
kippen sondern die bundesregierung ist
schafft geht's dir im chaos im griff zu
bekommen
denn nochmal wir tun unseren teilnehmern
zu hause bleiben unsere geschäfte liegen
brach unsere kinder werden nicht erzogen
wir machen unseren teil
da können wir verdammt nochmal verlangen
dass regierung auch ihren teil machten
das sieht nicht danach aus und das
schadet wiederum höhere akzeptanz dieser
maßnahmen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren